we have to at all times treat ourselves
with kindness if you screw up a
presentation kindness if you didn't get
the grade you wanted in your assessment
kindness okay if you went to work and
your annual review came back and it
wasn't quite as good as you're expecting
don't go out of that room with your boss
and berate yourself how could it be so
stupid what was I thinking why didn't I
put in more effort why didn't I work on
weekends or evenings or whatever to make
sure that this didn't happen kindness
it's okay it did my best I worked hard
nobody's perfect I made mistakes we're
human and to be human is to be imperfect
if we can learn to treat ourselves with
kindness every time something goes wrong
we will instantly start to break down
those sort of critical features of
perfectionism that make it such a
difficult personality trait to carry
around